what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports aka your eSports
dad okay so this Venn and mithi JumpShip
2na and now they're with TSM great what
could go wrong right well apparently
quite a lot they did not exactly have
the best week one in the NA LCS but with
that in mind here are our top ten is
vented mithi plays from better days
during Worlds 2015's group stages ven
who was then playing as Niels was able
to catch arrow too close to the bush and
landed a couple of key crits along with
so as his help he then followed up with
another kill on nog nade to propel OG to
a late-game advantage against the
favorite of kt rolster with a 5 v
forward peekaboo dead in school running
back up from the base yeah but really
something happened really chance moment
into game right now
has to be valid for origin missplay from
katie in this next play we get to see
that Sven and Miffy camaraderie play out
in games the two bot laners set up for a
level one invade on rockets Freddy and
earwax that set their opponents way
behind actually put xgk slightly behind
the tempo but exactly the same is going
to happen because rocket has no words to
see them they're not invading as fast
look at topside look at your mini-map
but I wonder if there's gonna be a kill
secured Freddy's going low oh but the
snuggler to airless exhaust comes out
followed by a flash minion spin
[Applause]
in week 2 of the 2016 summer split his
van and mithy were pushing mid together
against splices sen [ __ ] van was forced
to use his severe spell shield and sen
cucks saw the opportunity to land his
cassiopeia alt blitz van expertly turned
to dodge in a super pinning player that
during the EU LCS summer finals
mithy showed off some heroic teamwork to
save niels in a key moment at first it
looked like niels quirky was caught in
rain overs cocoon but at the last second
myth he saved the day with his Brom
shield that gave niels and the rest of
origins just enough time to swing the
fight in their favor once again here
Origen are so so strong in the mid game
this time around phonetic did not get
the engage they were looking for make
the magic frustrate but that's just the
support sometimes you just need a friend
to swoop in and bring you to safety here
the copenhagen wolves tried to catch
niels pushing too far up the bot length
but some colleen thresh play coupled
with a Calista alt were enough to get
both players out alive what team is
going to be able to challenge this
origin squad don't look too far Henry's
teleport Copenhagen wolves are going to
try to make that happen here Ashe arrow
comes out by a young buck on the
teleport locks up Niels
wax is gonna try to get at least
something but are you serious no one
dies on origin not today look at this
cooks adducts smiling it says yes that's
why I picked Calista Thresh for my boat
lane because they get out of four man
gang squad at Worlds 2015 Neal's in
mithy executed a crafty combo kill on
flash wolves sword art Miffy ate the
Taiwanese support with the tahm Kench
and then Neal's Calista ultied his bot
Lane her partner back into the waiting
jaws of origin with Calista to pick up
the kill she comes in on one side to
begin this one which is actually what
split up flash wolves to begin with
obviously good play by minty but then
Niels is playing caught sword on a nice
blank light there but he was just pulled
to the side yeah that was that was the
Calista tahm Kench combo that you dream
up when you see the champion kits and
they pull it off
[Music]
despite the gnar ultimate here Miffy was
able to get the knock up with his Alice
star Niels managed to save Miffy with a
Calista alt and a quick headbutt to a
minion allowed Oh G to grab a kill with
no casualties sure it comes out it does
land up to Mickey he's gonna be falling
today prior to second
that was fantastic play from mithy 0:04
and he is showing up on the big stage
once more at first it seemed like eels
was about to get dough Vai CLG but
instead he got the jump on huisman and
Niels it did not stop having it from the
ribbon old as well as the jinx rocket
yeah who he Louie playing with fire and
now that it sticks a very low it now if
this was doable if did a rocket jumping
it for this one he's gonna try it get
the reset job Sun passes off the story
two deals and that's a beautiful trip
once again it looked like Ben was about
to get caught out in top lane but some
crafty teamplay turned it around
his van was able to pull off a sweet
side step on Calista and then mithy
landed a big combo knock up on Alistar
to turn around the fight as well
thoughts is that to assist as allies
mérimée well with the Frank bow with a
big ultimate for one to kill 2 kills and
maybe the fifth as well figure out the
clean 8 the triple kill coming in for an
ace for origin and all on the back all
it's been doing that
absolutely and quick shot hey sis worth
discuss things during the 2017 spring
split as venon myth he showed off their
late-game resolved by turning this game
around right on the brink of defeat
unicorns of love charged the Nexus
looking to end the game but g2 wasn't
having any of that pulling out a
miraculous quadric hill to save the game
picks up XOR the Nexus he's going low
there's a double kill for Sven they
manage to finish it Daisy he's going to
be the only one
defend oh are you kidding there's one
damn head left span gets the coracle and
stops new culture ending the game I
teach you what you gonna do it they've
just got Nexus turrets left I mean
they're still eight seconds on Hill is
saying there's still five seconds on
samox they're gonna plow through the
rest of it it's 40 minutes into this
game what a wild what it's been but in
the end it is gonna be Jay to add zero
okay guys and that was our list and if
you notice all the plays are actually
from EU with that said I really hopes
Benham iffy have a better time in week
two of the NA LCS and by the way if you
thought their week one play was good
enough to highlight let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]